what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe and right now it's an extremely
exciting time to be a marvel fan marvel
studios has a ton in store for us as far
as disney plus projects and movies and
of course there's a ton of new awesome
projects coming that they haven't even
announced yet and one of those projects
that people seem to be talking about is
a world war hulk project the next movie
we would get from mark ruffalo's the
hulk but this movie will be different it
is not going to be like professor hulk
from avengers in game which a lot of
people didn't really like but the whole
point of this movie would be to give us
a full out rageful insane hulk which i
know a lot of fans want so let's talk
about what we could get from world war
hulk and also thank you to display for
sponsoring this video more in them in a
bit now i think that the world war hulk
movie that we could get is probably
going to be somewhat like an avengers
movie possibly like captain america
civil war for those of you who read the
comics you know that there are just a
ton of different superheroes in the
comic run and i think that the movie is
probably going to be pretty similar and
there are actually a few things that are
kind of setting up the world war hulk
story and one is really really important
and that is doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness now in the comics
it's the illuminati that send the hulk
off world because he is getting too
dangerous to keep on the planet and i
believe that in multiverse of madness we
are going to be introduced to an
illuminati but a multiversal illuminati
and i believe that after the film we are
going to get our own universe's
illuminati they may not be called that
but that's essentially what they're
going to be essentially there's going to
be some type of council after multiverse
of madness this is going to be so they
can keep the peace of the multiverse and
of course earth and this is a very
important part because ultimately these
are the people that the hulk is going to
come back and essentially try to kill
the next important part is the she-hulk
series now it's been confirmed that mark
ruffalo is going to be in the she-hulk
series which makes sense because he is
the cousin of she-hulk jennifer walters
in the comics she gets in a very bad
accident and is only saved because of a
blood transfusion with her cousin bruce
banner she inherits some hulk-like
abilities which essentially save her
life and make her she-hulk and then link
this with the post credits of shanxi and
the legend of the ten rings we saw bruce
banner not the hulk but bruce banner
normal human form again so clearly
something happened to make him revert to
a normal human being but here's where
things get different than where they go
in the comics and here's where world war
hulk is born in the comics the hulk gets
hit with a gamma bomb this causes him to
lose control and he attacks las vegas
the illuminati then get together and
decide that the hulk is too powerful to
keep on earth but of course they can't
kill him so they decide to trick him and
send him off world they tell him that
he's going to go into orbit to fix a
satellite but really they're sending him
to another planet i think that in the
movie whatever causes him to revert back
to bruce banner will eventually backfire
because i don't think he's going to get
hit with a gamma bomb but i think in the
process to reverse the hulk which
happened from gamma radiation he's going
to essentially expose himself to even
more gamma radiation the gamma chamber
as he called it in avengers in game and
essentially become hulked out again but
even worse than he's ever been before
and from here he's going to get out of
control and he probably will attack
something probably get in a fight with
some avengers or another hero perhaps
doctor strange as they attempt to try to
calm him down now it's most likely going
to be doctor strange because after
multiverse of madness after doctor
strange goes through everything he's
gonna be a lot more strict with what he
lets get away having learned a lot and
not wanting anything to go wrong again
on his watch he's going to have a lot
less tolerance which is why we'll
probably see a doctor strange vs hulk
fight originally now doctor strange
might be able to contain him for a
little bit and doctor strange might even
come out on top of the fight however the
hulk is just going to get angrier and
angrier and this is where the
conversation of the hulk being too
dangerous will begin now they might
discuss killing him but obviously
they're not going to be able to bruce
banner even said in the first avengers
he tried to kill himself he put a bullet
in the back of his head but the hulk
spit it out so the option is send him
off the planet so he can't destroy it
now in the comics they trick him but
perhaps in the movie they won't really
need to trick him if doctor strange can
contain him then perhaps they'll just
send him off planet now in the comics he
goes through a portal and ends up on
sakhar where he becomes a famous
gladiator and a leader and then he gets
a wife and she gets pregnant and
ultimately dies to an explosion the ship
that hulk originally took there exploded
killing his wife and future child this
is what causes him to go back to earth
and exact revenge sending him into full
world war hulk mode now i don't think
this is what's going to send him into
world war hulk mode in the movie i
actually think he's going to have maybe
a wife maybe even a future kid on earth
and i'll explain that in just a bit but
first thank you to dissplate for
sponsoring this video if you are a movie
fan of any kind displayed is for you
displayed is a one-of-a-kind metal
poster with a revolutionary magnetic
mounting system it's super unique it's
extremely easy and it's very safe for
your walls and no tools are required and
the best part is you can switch out the
posters that you love there are over 1.4
million designs that you could choose
from both branded and artistic designs
from marvel to star wars to dc to james
bond to cyberpunk whatever your passion
is there is something for you they're
also super durable because they're
printed on metal and they're printed in
the eu right now they're doing a
promotion for two weeks one or two disc
plates purchased gets you 23 off and if
you purchase three or more displays you
get 27 off they're also usually
delivered within four to five business
days so very fast just click the link in
the description down below to get your
displays so obviously we know that
movies never follow the comics exactly
as they are they take inspiration from
it but it's never exactly like it for
good measure we would already know the
story so i think that while the hulk is
finally turned back to bruce banner and
bruce banner as normal he perhaps meet
somebody maybe he gets married maybe
they're pregnant with a future baby from
here this is where he would get out of
control due to overexposure to gamma
radiation whether that's a bomb whether
that's a reverse effect of trying to
become normal again he's gonna hulk out
whatever it is causing him to go out of
control and this is where the rage comes
from the avengers sent him off planet
away from the woman he loves and
possibly future child and that's why he
wants to get back now when he gets back
is when things are really going to go
down because obviously since the
avengers or the illuminati or whatever
council of heroes there is sent him away
they're not just gonna welcome him back
with open arms and they're still going
to think that he's too dangerous to be
kept on earth now obviously the hulk
isn't just going to leave and this is
where the battle begins now i mentioned
that i thought it might be a little bit
like civil war and the reason i think
that is is because i think some heroes
might actually side with the hulk there
might be some heroes that say i can't
believe you sent hulk off planet you
sent him away from his wife from his
future kid there's gotta be a way to
help him i'm on the hulk side but then
you'll have people like dr strange hoop
say there was no other way we can't kill
him and he's too dangerous so we sent
him away and we have to send him away
again and this is where a battle will
break out a battle between the earth's
mightiest leaders and the hulk and
whoever decides to follow him now
ultimately in world war hulk it's
revealed when the hulk is in full rage
mode radiating gamma energy that is
harmful to the earth that it was
actually red king loyalist that blew up
the ship and meek knew about this but
decided not to stop them because he
wanted the hulk to destroy and keep
destroying so the hulk begins to get
insanely out of control but luckily tony
stark using some weaponized satellites
fires on the hulk and they revert him
back to bruce banner from there in the
comic shield would take control of him
and i think that this will happen in the
movie as well and i still think that
even though tony stark isn't here there
could be some hulk weaponized satellite
program that he put in place before he
died that they could use on the hulk
much like we saw in avengers age of
ultron there were hulk precautions put
into place i'm sure shield has those
precautions in place as well and i know
they have access to the satellites now
from here we might have another division
of heroes much like after captain
america civil war because there were
some people like namor the submariner
who voted against sending hulk off
planet because he predicted that he
would come back for vengeance so i do
think there might be somewhat of a
fallout again after world war hulk the
way everything is kind of lining up
right now leading to a new hulk movie it
does seem like these events are likely
to take place if they are going to draw
a lot of inspiration from the comics
regardless i am ready to see a full
rageful angry hulk again in the mcu
coming back and actually fighting the
heroes that we know and love but let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below are you excited for
world war hulk and what would you have
happen in the movie don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you